Was One of the Bond Girls Really Formerly
a Man?
That depends on how you define “man” and
“Bond girl”.
If you define “man” as a person who was
born with a penis and “Bond girl” as any
eye candy female that appeared in a Bond movie
at any point, then yes- one of the Bond girls,
or at least one of the women shown in a Bond
movie (not a main character by any stretch),
was born a man.
If you define “man” as someone born with
an XY chromosome pattern, rather than XX,
like a typical woman, then no.
You see, the woman in question, actress and
model Caroline Cossey, born Barry Kenneth
Cossey, was born with something known as Klinefelter
Syndrome, which means she has an XXY chromosome
pattern with 47 chromosomes, instead of 46.
This is a condition that occurs in about 1
in every 500-1000 male births (and significantly
more rarely occurs in females).
This makes it one of the most common chromosome
abnormalities known to man.
Some of the common side effects of this are
low testosterone levels compared to most males,
wider hips, less muscle mass, possible breasts
(in about 1/3 of the cases), generally infertile,
and significantly less body and facial hair,
among other things.
Now, traditionally those with Klinefelter
Syndrome have been called “XXY males”,
to distinguish them from “normal” XY males.
However, in the International Journal of Andrology
published in 2011,various researchers from
several Australian medical institutes proposed
in a paper, Thinking Outside the Square: Considering
Gender in Klinefelter Syndrome, that some
XXY “males” should actually be called
XXY “females” and others simply intersex.
The specific point of the paper was that perhaps
Klinefelter Syndrome should be detached from
“XXY”.
Most with this condition are clearly male
and identify as such, but a small percentage
seem to be female, and thus typical treatment
for Klinefelter Syndrome, including being
given testosterone starting during puberty,
may be damaging psychologically as it would
make the person’s body more male-like, when
in fact they were female.
As these treatments preferably start at a
very young age, the child may not be in a
position to assert this one way or the other.
(In another study, there was even a case where
the researchers came across a rare XXY female
(born with a vagina), who since childhood
had always thought of herself as a male and
demonstrated stereotypical male-like tendencies
from the beginning.)
While Cossey was indeed born with a penis,
throughout her youth she was extremely feminine
in personality, looks, and personal preference
tendencies, which often resulted in her getting
bullied at school.
She was also frequently mistaken for a girl
by those who didn’t know her.
(You can see in the picture to the right just
how feminine she looked as a teen.)
From this, if you buy into the medical researchers’
argument proposed in their paper, we’d perhaps
say that Cossey was one of those XXY’ers
who, while born with a penis, was actually
an XXY female.
In her late teens, after dropping out of school
and working a few odd jobs, she became friends
with a transsexual and at that point, at the
age of 17, started hormone therapy.
She also started working as a showgirl and
later, after breast surgery, as a topless
dancer.
Once she’d saved up enough to be able to
pay for sex reassignment surgery, she had
that done too with her final surgery in 1974.
She started modeling before her reassignment
surgery and continued under the name “Tula”
after with a lot of success, appearing in
numerous magazines, including some adult magazines
where she’d pose topless.
She later even appeared in a 1981 edition
of Playboy.
She also would have started a role as a model
in a game show in 1978, but she quit the show
when a journalist discovered she was born
with a penis and was going to break the story.
Unfortunately, her career was severely stunted
from this as she had to try to keep a low
profile to keep her secret from being published.
This all ended in 1981 when she appeared in
the Bond, For Your Eyes Only, film and the
story broke, for a time being front page news.
The aftermath of this was initially devastating
to Cossey who was sure her career as a model
was over, but eventually she moved on and
continued modeling, as well as writing two
autobiographies, the second of which, My Story
was written in 1992.
She’s today married to Canadian David Finch;
the two recently
celebrated their 20th anniversary.